- [Narrator] Guatemala is
known for a lot of things.
Coffee, avocados, but
more than anything else,
it should be known for chocolate.
(jazzy music)
This is a place called Chocolá.
It's known for rain and fertile soil,
which means it's an ideal
place to grow cacao,
the main ingredient in chocolate.
The ancient Maya grew it
there 2,500 years ago,
and people are still
growing it there today.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] So after the cacao is grown.
It's off to the chocolatiers.
Brenda is a fourth generation chocolatier.
She makes her chocolate the same way
her great-grandmother
used to back in the day.
And now she's teaching her
children to do the same.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] This is Fernando.
He's a newer chocolatier,
taking a more modern approach
to Guatemala's chocolate renaissance.
(speaking foreign language)